[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'll mention blue
[Music]
you're taking me back
you're taking me back
[Music]
please welcome to the stage he's a
casual gamer but professionally loud
give it up for courage jd
[Music]
sneaking past you
let's go everybody
wow
thank you thank you first off
i'd like to thank everyone for coming
out tonight for the world premiere of
call of duty vanguard
[Applause]
now i've personally never been part of a
premiere before and i can probably speak
for all of us when i say i've never
walked a camo carpet before in my life
but tonight's festivities are worthy of
it all
we've got a show like you would not
believe
we're going to be seeing some amazing
gameplay
streamers
artists
head-to-head matchups and more surprises
than you can imagine
and to start it all off
we're going to get a first look at the
incredible vanguard campaign
of course sledgehammer needed a an elite
pro gamer
to really showcase what you can do
so they picked me
that's where i come in
let's get started
[Applause]
all right
i put it on veteran by the way
not recruit
[Music]
well
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go and wait but we should see who
they are with another family
[Music]
short
this sniper shot precise
you think they might be
okay there's more cover this way
come on
[Music]
wow
so how will you kill steiner lady
nightingale i told you to stop calling
me that the name gives the survivors
hope paulina
hope would win this
and
war
to followers of lady nightingale
anyone who gives asylum to this
terrorist will face the most severe
penalties
let's go up this way
now you know
just want to be clear
sometimes it could you know i might miss
but
it'll be very rare they sat me down here
instead of symphony because they know
i'll hit my shots unlike him so
take a look
steiner
he's driving towards the commercial
district you may be right about those
jager murders misha
let's move before we lose sight of him
misha be careful
get down what do we do
try drawing fire with my knife do what
just trust me
no no no no no
no no no no no
no no no no no
i don't want to hear it
oh
[Applause]
there they go let's go there they go
it's all part of you know come on
look you want me to really show up okay
fine fine fine
[Music]
oh
where is he
kind of a 360 right where are you
where always on the left
[Music]
[Applause]
now keep it
no no
like i get it we're in a big studio it's
really cool but
we're just missing something man like
this isn't
this could just be so much better
if if only i brought my personal
20-person
orchestra
that follows me around
everywhere i go i mean
have been so much cool
unless unless i did
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen i give you joey
newman and the vanguard world premiere
orchestra
wow
i mean chills through that whole thing
that was uh that was absolutely
incredible joey um
but i have a better idea
hear me out hear me out okay
let's do something that's never been
done in call of duty history shall we
how about
the orchestra
plays along with me
live
well i'm game let's do it
ladies and gentlemen i give you
vanguard live
[Applause]
it's not happening again
come on now
[Music]
hey hey
i want it i want it even louder i want
to not be able to even hear my own
thoughts
all right zuma's here i want him to have
to plug his ears okay all right let's go
if i'm down
[Music]
oh it's gonna be perfect perfect
[Music]
no
oh
no
i gotta reload
i gotta reload i gotta reload
i need to breathe i need to breathe
there's a lot of pressure on me right
now
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
one more
bye
come on now
[Music]
what is this
[Music]
oh oh hell no oh no no no no no no i'm
good i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good
this guy's a tank
[Music]
excuse me
sure
[Music]
well
we should be safe from now
hey look uh
by the way you see this jacket i'm
wearing
if you're watching out there right now
you can win this jacket which
technically i don't allowed to say has
the brand new warzone full map stitched
on the inside uh tweet hashtag vanguard
hashtag sweepstakes for a chance to win
okay let's get back in
[Music]
hey joey joey yeah you guys sound great
can we just quiet that i want to hear
that you want you want to hear it all
yeah yeah sorry you guys are doing great
but this is kind of why i'm here
[Music]
let's try to get closer
[Music]
i can't wait to put the bullet through
steiner's head
wait
this is bad for nina
we can't stream
[Music]
bastard
is superior
get down
[Music]
[Music]
no
[Music]
[Music]
your breathing
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
let's move
really this the ridiculous music when i
get killed that's what we have to do
that's that's the way to go
all right
we go back also no one told me someone
had a bayonet on this level so
i'm carrying a half dead guy and i have
a pistol
[Music]
steady your breathing
[Music]
i have you
come on out
[Music]
[Music]
stay with me
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
he won't make it
that's gotta hurt
this knife isn't going to get us out of
here
[Applause]
look we need to
you're delirious come on we have to move
oh
you cover the opening i go out and flank
them yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it uh it wouldn't be a quality
stream if we didn't have
f's in the chat right now
for whoever's watching online you know
you know
[Music]
[Music]
all right keep on your toes you know
you guys are the ones providing the
music
[Music]
all right i'm sorry
[Music]
steiner
[Music]
all right
[Music]
hey joey how about every time i take
someone down can you give me like an
inception like
as loud as you can please
it's the best movie of all time so
way better than interstellar
oh oh oh hold up no no no
i don't understand what you're saying
all right right now
[Music]
okay
okay hold on here
three two one
man
that is satisfying you have more for me
wait we can we can do this all night oh
yeah
i'll fight you right now joey
you get a box to stand on to be taller
okay i'm still five nine
six three
[Music]
[Music]
all right
all right
[Music]
oi susan
[Music]
how athletic is she oh my god
oh
foreign
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's the idea no don't cheer for them
doing that to me
jesus christ i said a heart attack
that was unnecessary
aries you got knocked the whole [ __ ] out
dude what happened hold on that was an
actual cut scene we all we all agree
right that wasn't me getting knocked out
i mean
who even is that i'd like to see you
come out here and do a better job in
front of a lot oh
man
i thought you'd never ask
hey yo joey joey joey joey
you got something for me bro
indeed i do hit me with a dan
three four
[Music]
[Music]
so when you think of legends i am one of
those kings the whole pleaser you don't
vote please i'm your host tonight so
feel free to host these
big brainerd a broke gamer other
channels
oh they know
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
how's everybody doing tonight
[Applause]
you killed it hey and then you got
killed well so
i mean honestly looking at looking at
you know us three you know which one of
us do you guys think is the most
talented
if you ask me i'm going to say joey
yeah joey right
t-pain
mutual musical no love here no no no no
no no you know what i'm done i'm done
okay i'm uh i'm out of here so bye have
fun you literally just died in front of
everybody else
subscribe to youtube.com get the [ __ ]
out
oh my god ladies and gentlemen give it
up for the one the only encouragement
i hope y'all guys had a good time seeing
him get killed so many times uh i'm
going to tell you the truth that [ __ ]
wasn't in the schedule we're behind as a
[ __ ] right now
he was supposed to run through that he
practiced earlier hey so listen
our orchestra is going to give you guys
a live scored preview of the rest of the
vanguard campaign so guys joey
take it away
[Applause]
so
[Music]
so
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
good
oh my god
shhh
what
how much can i cuss
what's the policy on that ladies and
gentlemen if you just felt like you grew
some extra body hair that's very normal
uh that was called music i don't know if
we've heard that in a few years but
that's what it sounds like a little bit
guys give it up
[Applause]
[ __ ] that was a banger i'm gonna need to
hire y'all to come play behind me on my
stream or something when i drop in the
warzone
maybe a little quick collab a little
auto-tune on the viola we kill her make
a [ __ ] hit uh but guys thank
you for coming out tonight ladies and
gentlemen give it up one more time for
joey newman and the vanguard world
premier orchestra
you killed it that was good oh please by
all means everybody take a bath i'll
take one with you just
i don't know the protocols that could
tell them to leave or not uh okay that's
fine uh do we have anybody that can come
move this [ __ ] i don't know if
y'all seen the t-pain show before but i
actually need somebody to come move this
i i'd like to there we go thank you i
appreciate that hold up hold up once i
get let me
grab
this real quick
you don't need this y'all don't need
this i don't think y'all need this
listen so
this is nasty as [ __ ] uh
and now
for an experiment that has gone horribly
horribly awry
they're
back they're bloodier than ever
they're here to steal your soul
and your [ __ ]
[Applause]
let's get this [ __ ] cracked
[Music]
[Applause]
the nazis dream of a thousand year reich
but in truth they are already dead
they've all machine shattered at
stalingrad but the evil regime staggers
on desperate to snatch victory from the
jaws of defeat
a special battalion of ss troops scoured
the globe for a supernatural means to
win the war
they were led by the most dangerous man
i ever met
your wolfram von list it was he who
destroyed my life wouldn't cost me my
soul
von list gathered experts from across
iraq archaeologists explorers historians
and authorities on the account like
myself they were forced to help them
loot sacred antiquities but none of the
relics we found gave von lists the power
he craved
then something happened in poland and
changed everything
another nazi attempt to alter the course
of the war somehow weakens a barrier
between this world and the next
unleashing the forces of darkness
many miles away five of our artifacts
suddenly
awakened
[Music]
ancient spirits demons if you will
beckon from these otherworldly relics
a promise of power
[Applause]
and of course
for least acceptance
[Music]
[Music]
he now has the power to raise the dead
in they plan to take back every single
nuts he's lost
all the troops he will ever require life
throws who means the best graves of the
eastern front
to stop his unholy army
they must fight their eyes a thousand
year life
will consume us all
yeah boy
[Applause]
i'm excited as [ __ ] what is going on in
here this is crazy
oh my god guys
i hope we're ready
because now
it's time to turn this [ __ ] up to 11.
okay
oh yeah oh you thought that was 11. that
was an 11.
i got at least one more notch
we got a taste of the incredible
campaign that awaits and call of duty
vanguard
and we're gonna move on to the part that
i love the most
[ __ ] multiplayer and
tonight we cooked up something special
for the first time ever we are teaming
up with versus to bring you
versus
call of duty vanguard edition yeah
that's right
shout out to swizzler tim love y'all
[Applause]
we'll be watching some of the biggest
artists in the game go head-to-head in
vanguard to start us off
we're doing something that's never been
done before it's the battle of the
century
let's make some noise for the lilz
versus the bigs
[Applause]
yes
i think we're doing a good job this is
going good so far
this is good
some good ass pictures jesus
[Music]
y'all didn't use my pictures that i
stand that was crazy
i sent like 10 pictures y'all use it
under mine that's cool
that's all right i was like with that
[Music]
guys
yeah
it's that time
ladies and gentlemen give it up give it
up give it up give it up
yeah
boy
what's happening what's that what's that
how you doing brother you feeling good
i hope so
look look look look look how slow we got
this is ridiculous
[Music]
come on ladies and gentlemen let me let
me let me let me let me get a little
applause for my homeboy little john
and my homeboy big sean
this um
skeet skeet indeed my friend
uh
they brought their most expensive jury i
will tell you that i bought little to
nothing they did not tell me was doing
this uh this isn't something to be taken
lightly now let me ask you something a
little john
are you ready for this fierce
competition cause this ain't this ain't
like a little bit of something this is
this is a huge deal are you ready am i
ready are you ready can y'all hear me
connect can y'all hear john
check there it is turn my goddamn mic up
ladies and gentlemen
yes i'm ready yes i'm ready you ready
for this you you've been practicing at
home a little bit you got you played the
beta okay
sean
now i will say this you're one of the
most confident man i've ever met in my
life uh
yeah that's a cool trait that's a cool
trait you think so i think so but how
confident are you tonight that you're
doing something that you actually suck
at
you're not good at call of duty i've
seen you play one time it wasn't a good
time i'm just saying how are you going
to do tonight what's going on with it
tonight are you confident about tonight
you think you're ready it's a new day
man you can't judge people off of
anything but a new day this is
two months ago
i think they're ready i guess you think
they're ready guys you think you're
ready
i'm still not sure
[Applause]
guys
hey
holding it down for the bigs we got uh
the other the bigger half of outcast we
got big boy alongside with hell
hold on like i said alongside with him
i just want to make sure we get this
correct yes not one
not two
not three but four platinum albums this
man that i just saw not do great at call
of duty give him a big shot one more
time
[Laughter]
little john
hey don't nobody give a [ __ ] about no
albums right now right now hey we got to
put out every accolade we can the man
with the most jury uh so we got look
little john all right i want you to be
confident in this i know you're i know
you're also very confident okay
it's okay i'm just saying it's a it's a
lot of talent in this room man i'm okay
you know what we're gonna figure this
out uh guys everybody's feeling
confident everybody's feeling good are
you guys feeling good about this
competition
[Applause]
all right
lils and bigs taking places cause we
about to get it cracking
fighting along the side of the list
tonight
that's what we got guys call of duty
league pros abc and tell him let's go
out there give it up some dog
i think we're doing
i think we're doing pretty good tonight
you guys feeling good i hope everybody's
feeling good over there because this is
already just
it's a weird setup not gonna lie to you
but
you gotta make a billion dollars in the
first day i feel like we got the budget
we got the budget we got everybody here
it's all good
if i don't if somehow we don't do good
it's because the setup is kind of like
the setup is weird
you know okay
we don't usually play with with you know
controller we're more of a mouse
keyboard hold on ladies and gentlemen
give it up for big boy
what's happening
oh you know i'm good you know i'm good
brother bound down to greatness that's
how it works yeah good very good yes sir
welcome to the welcome to the welcome to
the game brother yeah yeah okay yeah
yeah we got it ready how you feeling now
you feeling confident this evening how
are you feeling um i'm super fantastic
super fantastic yes that's two great
things okay
little john said i look like an african
superhero i didn't know what that meant
but he said it real strong so it was
weird
but fighting alongside the lils tonight
we got call of duty league pros of bees
and selling but also
fellow streamers and content creators
sean jay and squid
oh my god
and on the big team
we got call of duty league pros enabling
slasher give it up
but also we got the content creators
queen shadows and crusader let's [ __ ]
make some noise in here please
yeah
i feel like it's not fair how much help
y'all got tonight y'all got a lot of
help and if y'all win you're gonna look
good and if you lose you're gonna look
really bad so
i'm praying for y'all
but i'm also kind of hoping for you to
fail this is not a good deal today
oh i'm just i'm amazing definitely i'm
dope have you all seen me play call of
duty have y'all seen me playing gold
i mean not vanguard i die a lot on
vanguard don't do not go look up clips
of me playing vanguard but this
everything else is fine
guys see i ain't playing no beta
vanguard i didn't play no this is my
first time it's your first time playing
the first time i'm making excuses early
just so you can okay
i think we're all set for the smackdown
in the century guys i'm going to kick it
upstairs to the best characters in the
business we got maven and lucy may who's
going to be giving us the play-by-play
through all the action tonight maven
what do you got for us
tv thank you sir uh no we're excited
this is going to be amazing we got
celebs so we got some professional
players streamers we've got everything
and i can't wait to see them do battle
because so far i mean the opening of the
show was one of the more ludicrous
things i've ever seen having my one of
my best friends in jack with an
orchestra behind him some of the worst
accuracy i've ever seen ever and he'd
somehow managed to die in a campaign
tutorial mission yeah it was pretty
pretty salty down in the green room over
there if only courage had heard what was
going down but maven i think he's going
to give it a little bit to him during
these casts
it's an homage to courage and like maybe
the
comparing of the gameplay like oh if
only courage could have hit it like that
well it can't get worse i mean that's
all the pressure is basically off all
the players competing in this so it's
gonna be amazing but uh not only to see
the all-new call of duty vanguard
multiplayer in full display but also a
rivalry that's almost too big for words
this is gonna be littles versus the
biggs it's the best two out of three no
mercy no holding back uh lucy uh talk to
me what do we get into here well maven
first you said it i too am thrilled to
be a part of this inaugural edition of
versus gaming and cannot wait to see all
of the new world of war world war ii map
excuse me and the loadouts it's about
the hype so for our first game we're
going to jump into some domination on
castle which is a reimagining of
treyarch's classic map from call of duty
world at war this is how i want to start
it off right here maven yeah see i'm
going to tell you this the first thing i
saw when i looked at the team so i was
sitting with uh slasher and
sellium and uh talking to them about
what their teams are going to be and
there are four professional players here
okay so celium on one side gets a beezy
abeezie is probably one of the more
twisted
talented players i've ever seen in my
life
slasher gets enabled
okay
enables no longer in the pro league
enable had a great career
it's a little lopsided with a beezy on
one side and enable on the other but i
don't know maybe enable feel the
pressure he'll step it up he's done some
crazier things
okay he's also playing with half a thumb
which is already hard wait what do you
mean he like he lost half of his thumb
in some sort of accident he's one of the
greatest fps players of all time i don't
know how he does it oh no he's he's
going to do it now right here
yeah so i mean i think we're ready to
get this into right now our map number
one first matchup for this event
multiplayer action going down i love it
we get to see everything that's
happening right here let's go let's kick
it in right oh i just realized the one
screw we have every single gameplay i
don't know what i'm gonna do with that
but we have it all there if we need it
we can see everything so we see what
every single player is doing right now
so i think you're being a little
squirrely that you the broadcast can't
see it we can so we're gonna call it out
we look good in these jackets too don't
we well no everyone's so so she showed
up this is gonna be like a red carpet
walk-in right
she was so glamorous like looked like
she was ready to be next to like brad
pitt coming in i i i showed up in a
t-shirt they gave me a bomber jacket so
i am feeling good but it's time to get
into map one littles versus biggs as we
get into it i don't i don't expect i
mean i'm pretty familiar with the pro
player some of the streamers but for the
artists i i've got no idea what their
capability is i mean t-pain was talking
to him seems like some people have
played some haven't some got the gunny i
don't know what to expect but it's uh
it's pretty dope to be getting into this
exclusive action here for vanguard it is
and whoa we're already getting some
eliminations happening right out the
gate too everyone's feeling good look at
this this gunplay what that was solid
did you see that mayman come on now put
your phone down boy all right we're in
some action hey this that's where i have
my secret special vanguard notes you
know my key talking points but so this
is so the mounting already you know it
was wild we saw it introduced in the
last title but now now you've got the
ability to strafe with it which we're
gonna see some um he's just looking for
a key position to get set up and i do
feel bad for him but he's gonna run into
any of the top pro players that's for
sure well big boy already got that cup
that red solo cup already ready to go
he's getting hyped he's ready look at
that beard dude like you were saying you
were kind of wanting to grow yours out
of it like you know i'd like to hear it
i've kept it i've always kept it tight
but i do think i there's some sort of
like gandalf type thing going on like a
really long beard i look very very good
yes it's movember you know you can work
on that yeah i'll try to it's fine all
right so we're kicking it in this is
beautiful look at the contrast right now
just from the natural foliage from the
browns and then all the way to the pinks
okay well all i saw was red and that was
the blood of four people being destroyed
it was a streak from celia that blew the
legs off multiple players and this is
not a guy so sally me is incredible he's
an unreal talent now have i seen him
compete in a blazer before have i seen
him in a blazer period before no
but the guy's still twisting some
streaks he's working on
locked in dialed in excited to see him
in a new title but uh one of the most
talented young players
on the globe i mean he's definitely
looking dapper look at that he's got the
little pocket square
but then he died and t-pain would be
like man why you got to be dying all the
time which is fine you know we're
getting it down with the blazer action
happening getting some streamers coming
in hot with these new weapons do you
have a favorite weapon at all i mean
this kind of throwback and so
it's almost like less the the weapons
that i'm excited to mess around with i
mean i love a new weapon i'm gonna be
wrong but like the fact that then
now
i mean you had what the first time the
gunsmith came in you put five
attachments on now the fact that you can
put ten so like i just feel like the
combos are gonna be unbelievable and
celium now i mean it's just like a
juggernaut on the map that did not look
fun to deal with at close range at all
oh hey slasher smiling i i i someone saw
the screen shot that slasher is smiling
that is rare
clearly clearly yes you're standing
right next to me and i got a definite
earphone
this is last year everyone's having a
good time though see if that's a rare
case you know slasher smiling we're
having a good time here at world
premiere for vanguard it is popping off
enable now someone tapped that jaw up a
little bit
he's getting serious those ginger girls
too
slasher smiling sometimes is a very rare
sight that's why i had to yeah yeah we
got it somebody clip it we're gonna
we're gonna immortalize that for sure
great incoming oh look at the new icon
looking snazzy with that so you were
mentioning about the 10 attachments and
those in the fact that those they can
also change
the ammo that your gun takes
i mean based on the attachments you have
it's like everything yeah it's so
customizable i mean it's unlike anything
we've ever seen in a call of duty before
which is exciting and also i mean a
little
i don't know what to expect right it's
like whenever there's something
introduced that we haven't seen before
it's uh i'm like a little nervous i'm
excited i can't wait to see how it's
gonna be used in the action but the
accommodations are gonna be insane yeah
oh we got a little tucker just pop it
off on the board
but now we're at that bz
bringing in some of that phase 11 okay
take that look at that they broke down
the map right just shoot down the boards
clear it up get some better sight lines
yeah that's another thing that's kind of
it's new right like these destructible
environments how are they going to make
a play in and around objectives or
anywhere on the map but it was a trip
cap for the blue squad for a moment
looks like able to get b back oh and now
c
is the double lining up
okay now the streaks coming in missile
from above please let it hit it's
look oh i thought it was doing multiple
ways at least it's one it's one yeah
there's at least one nobody's hiding in
there
what have you but
crusader
now running through i mean
fantastic use of just
these weapons here i mean i keep
referring back to the weapons because
that's what i like playing around with
the guns you know what i like
fast what's that
what's it the most important thing i
mean you can talk as much as you want
about the maps and the looks of it but
the gun plays where it's at right like
how the guns look and feel like i don't
want to say it's everything but you got
to get that right and just i mean from
the looks of it so far i think people
have a lot to be excited for yeah so
it's seeming like we our scoreboard's a
little bit kind of covered but that's
fun it's looking like the team lil is in
the lead
they're doing a great job being able to
get those
objective points and the kills doing a
great job
so let's see how we're on board here
with okay we're gonna be back oh yeah i
have no idea who's winning or losing but
i'm gonna have fun talking over the
action no clue what the story is like i
think i see a little bit of blue peeking
out a little farther than the red
team lou
listen they're gonna do work they're
gonna know who won and lost they're
gonna be the ones doing the trash talk
we're just gonna call people
embarrassing themselves or any amazing
plays they get that's what we're here
for yeah that's why i wish i was casting
over jack's action earlier because that
was utter and absolute [ __ ]
that would have been fantastic i mean i
already got an earful of your commentary
for all of that yeah but yes if anyone
else could have had the opportunity to
hear what i did it was glorious but kurt
did a great job we can't wait to play
the campaign that was not safe for
camera though
all right
all right wait was that did we hear are
we hearing some player audio too
are we getting player cam or was that
just in game maybe just for a second
yeah that might have been a little bit
of it yeah all right all right big boy
coming through
but then i'm gonna hop over with enable
but we got a beezy we see him popping
off in the kill feed so that's gonna be
oh for the team lil again
yeah they're skating on their lead i
don't know if you saw any of the clips
that came out during the beta from a
beezy and simple but it didn't look like
it was a whole lot of fun to play
against um is they were absolutely
toying with people i think that was four
or five in a row for bc and god knows
how many that is stacked up wait oh what
is happening i'm not sure no he was
about to destroy everybody pure
destruction and it was destroyed in
itself imploded what
looks like we might be having some
technical issues
i've never been teased for my whole life
that might that tends to happen in live
events everybody so it's fine we're
gonna get things going back online
as we are great viewers yeah that's a
perfect spot
hi there
well what a time what a time for it to
stop for a second that literally missile
inbound above like four people of these
is about to pop off and blow the entire
map
hey listen this whole thing has been a
circus like all of it coming together
with the orchestra and the setup and the
pros here the live environment and the
red carpet and it has been a lot of fun
but yeah sometimes part of that
technical issues we apologize for a bit
of the tease there with the street
coming in but
we'll get back to the action as soon as
we can yeah and so now you guys are
stuck with us for a hot second and uh
yeah we're just going to be able to you
guys while we get distorted we're going
to bring it out back over to t-pain on
the stage
i'm gonna go ahead and just blame this
on the bigs i'm just go ahead and just
blame that on the banks
uh
big boy what'd you do
what'd you do you broke something you
you obviously
yeah good lord
well guys
hello john the action is not over
we still got a lot coming up
did y'all see who was lacking and i feel
like somebody's going to use this as an
excuse to lose
it's not going to be a good excuse i
don't think that's going to be good
man i saw a lot of people slacking on
the gameplay but
not gonna criticize you yet until you
fully lose i want to see a full round of
you [ __ ] up then we'll be okay i
think we'll be good
are you doing over there john
yeah
i didn't want to go as aggressive
as you thank god
yeah
hey you seen me
what what you seen me
who me
oh
outside you know what
shawn you look like you knew what you
was doing i'm not going to say
that you were doing great it looked like
you had good intentions
[Laughter]
it looked like you knew what was going
on john you got to get on the map at
some point
get into action you got to run towards
the gunshots
you can't camp with smg this is weird
it's a weird thing you're doing all
right
you can't be camping john
he was camping with an smg
hey little john was [ __ ] mounted on
everything rocks
rock come on crate rock
[Laughter]
that was the mount king get on it like
that [ __ ] i didn't get back on yet
oh [ __ ]
nobody told me about the temperature in
this [ __ ]
uh what's going on i thought i was gonna
be good wearing this jacket lagging for
updates
the president of wakanda and this
[ __ ] i told you boy
what happened to you
what you got
why are we doing teams
[Music]
oh you can just say i sit the [ __ ] down
t-pain okay that's cool i'll be uh
all right hey so we got we got a
multiplayer sneak peek
[Music]
if we got a multiplayer sneak peek and
i'm don't sit my ass y'all you know what
y'all
[Music]
warriors
saboteurs
assassins
their lives turned upside down by the
right
each one with an axe to grind and when
we turn them loose
you better believe
they're coming out swinging
[Music]
[Music]
got it
[Applause]
[Applause]
oh
[Applause]
so
[Music]
i can't see the enemy
[Music]
[Music]
prophecy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you're taking me back
yeah yeah
action-packed
[Music]
[Laughter]
all right so uh
today no uh
i will say this
when they when when that when that just
happened
the lills were winning at the time no
no no
we was coming back second half now
here's the thing sean
we don't have time for that [ __ ] that
you just talked about
so i will say by default when that
happened
team little one on that on that round
yeah yeah i i i
they have a they have a person if you're
at home watching this and you feel like
this is unfair i understand
but also if you're at home and you're
one of them people that won't shut the
[ __ ] up let people finish a game then
you know maybe you're part of the
problem listen guys uh team lil won that
round give it up for team left
[Applause]
tacky you feel like you did a good job
buddy got to be man come on we don't do
nothing you feel like you did a good job
you think so you think he was you think
he was dirty okay okay okay okay john
you feel the same way i'm good oh tackle
yeah okay that makes sense i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna dwell on what i saw on the
screen i'm just gonna let y'all do your
thing over there and i appreciate y'all
uh
all right hey
so officially now the score is 1-0 the
teams are getting prepped for the next
match
i'm excited to see what happens next
uh maybe lucid may it's over to you get
to it
thank you thank you okay now i i don't
listen i don't work in league office i'm
not sure if giving the moon was the
right or fair thing to do but we're
going to go ahead and stick with it so
team littles they got the 1-0 edge uh we
had a big tease at the end of that beezy
at the missile coming in thought i was
going to pop off like a four piece
hopefully now we're ready though to get
into the game second game yeah that was
definitely a cliffhanger so hopefully
we're gonna be able to go through into
the second matchup but hey let's take a
look back on some action that had
happened that before we were able to
lose out on all that but look at this
we're getting some excitement going down
with some of our players here streamers
and our celebrities just popping off and
there's the one of them that did happen
to pop off yeah actually connected yeah
that makes it a little bit easier to
follow right for those of you watching
at home i mean
we're just we're having fun we're
enjoying the action we've got the
celebrities the pros i mean i i couldn't
tell you the score half the time because
i literally can't see it behind we're
just here to enjoy uh it's a celebration
of a new call of duty title coming out
which is uh one of those
my favorite times if not my favorite
time of the entire year it's like death
and taxes you know it's coming you get
ready for it it's a glorious glorious
time if you missed the beginning please
go back and watch it because i still
think i i've worked
i've been working on call of duty for
probably seven or eight years now i have
done and seen a lot of silly and absurd
things
the whole orchestra thing
with jack playing was one of the most
insane things i've seen and the t-pain
coming out like freestyling talking [ __ ]
on them it was incredible yeah i don't
know when i'll see that again but i love
everyone for being a part of well you
can go back and like you said watch the
body that's how you can see it again
maven yep but it was pretty incredible
but all right hey map number two game
number two we're gonna hop on in right
now it's going to be some
desert siege action
look at all the wind maven it's just
moving around
well this this one
i've been excited to see just i haven't
personally played patrol yet but
hardpoint has been
part of you know uh the call of duty
esports for a really long time but now
to my understanding it's like kind of
one point instead of it topping to set
positions it's just sort of a constant
rotating hardpoint around the map which
i'm pretty excited to see because i
haven't had a chance to try it
yeah we're definitely making our players
work for it today so we hope these guys
have been practicing because then on
this map they've got to be mobile
they've got to be able to adapt quickly
and this right here just look at it in
all its glory it's north africa with
lots of natural defilade you can see
it's already popping off sand dunes rock
formations so we're definitely going to
see how these players use this to their
advantage okay you just came out of the
bushes and said surprise
every time i see it now you talk with a
sand dune like i guess i've just seen
since what a dune come out like a week
and a half ago something like that i've
watched it probably every day since then
so i see sand and i'm immediately
transported to
arrakis some mystical sci-fi planet
that's where i am in my head right now
except now we're in call of duty yes no
that's
that's where my brain is i just want to
let you know yeah well and i'm bringing
you back this is vanguard in all of its
glory oh gosh it's silly i'm going off
again so there's no giant worms
i don't know i haven't seen dune yet so
let's you know
maybe that's a spoiler that's my best
friend's over here okay
first courage then you well that's what
the ball is
just kidding
we're just busting your butt courage we
love you
all right so actions pop it up all right
so you see it see it there like the
objective is just like a slowly ever
moving kind of power point which is
i i don't even know how that would i
don't i haven't like messed her up the
sponsor but see how that play out but
it's a really interesting idea just
constantly moving fight around the
points again
a king of the hill or a hard point
that's just so weird always evolving and
moving and somebody you know soaking up
the time inside is trying to get the
objective points for their squads you
know the lil's up 100
you still don't know about the judgment
on that but right now i saw a beezy
squad they are dominating and he's at
the top of the scoreboard once again
yeah lil bizzy's uh
abc's team is team lil and they are just
dominating did you mention that out of
the case he said that that was kind of a
lopsided affair bill beezy kind of
sounds like
another brand you know just maximize all
of your what is that your legacy your
brand now it's you to see them
dominating easy with a mic trying to
like rap on stage that's pretty much the
only thing i need i'm good for the
entire night yeah versus games uh you
know showdown yeah all right let's get
it easy okay
but all right i do love like you said
this the
point is moving it's slow you can see it
is
slowly rolling through and it's in the
open too that's fantastic you can't just
like toss a nade into a building because
it's a hard point and everyone's gonna
hold it down her headquarters excuse me
oh yeah no it's uh
wait i guess
i love it we're here like a tiny bit of
the player cops i don't know what's
coming through some of the rage you hear
from the players is just absolutely
incredible but the [ __ ] you keep
following me yeah i hope everyone's
hearing what we're hearing well i think
it's coming from like the art like the
artists and celebrities right like the
pro player is like locked in like cell
hasn't said a thing his face hasn't
moved i'm not even sure he's breathing
what do you hear like the artist going
off they're just talking trash to each
other it's so good oh my gosh slasher
went in 3k
crushing it but it's team big
closing the gap a little bit but team
look at that they're so close to winning
this next or the second match up
yeah i think i saw enable and slash like
that you know the 35 plus club popping
off they had like six or seven straight
into kill feed they're hitting it you
got to think yeah yeah this type of play
style
yeah you know
you can play fast you can see the movie
gets a little bit cracked but you get
into position somebody like slasher he
can line it up with an ar no questions
asked yeah all right well i mean
speaking of what's happening in our ears
with our players let's take let's give
our audience some of that action right
now
[Music]
oh watch out watch out what come on man
i just stepped out in the middle but
they throwing bombs and [ __ ]
let's go man [ __ ] this [ __ ]
yeah now whoever that is
i got 11. i got 11.
[Music]
what
hey we got to step it up man
i know i just hit him eight times
dang it
hey [ __ ] we at all the time man we got
to step up man
[Music]
i don't want to see the car there's no
cart oh
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
boy that was a roller coaster yeah look
tucker
[Music]
look hey okay i'm not gonna lie i saw
you doing good sean
big boy what maybe not so much not gonna
lie to you bombs over back down he was
it
bombs over baghdad you got no bombs
you failed sir
[Laughter]
john you had high alert and didn't give
a [ __ ] about it you just you suck
his two whole goddamn screen was orange
look not running away it's god damn i
need another gun
well guys i mean i don't really have to
announce this team little one that one
uh
all the way that was legit
okay
okay god damn babies didn't come to god
damn play no [ __ ] games either
i tell you that [ __ ]
look i'll tell you what how about this
how about this
y'all lost
but just because i'm a nice person and i
don't want to waste this suit and we
need more time on air
we going to play another match just to
let y'all try to get you all [ __ ]
together okay is that cool
y'all got pro players over there i told
you if you lose you're gonna look way
worse
than anybody else you gotta roll players
over there
and real content creators okay people
that do this [ __ ] for a living i can't
help y'all win
weird guys we're gonna play a third
match
and we're gonna try to help team big
make up
for that first match is that cool
i feel like i feel like that's only fair
y'all was kind of cheated out the first
match probably would have lost anyways
but now we're gonna let y'all make up
for this one here we go
david lucy please tell us what we're
doing for mastery thank you
all right thank you welcome back we were
good you did good you got it you got
okay we were fixing some technical
issues what's happening mike's on the
right side making sure our hairs are
both uh yes
it's all right this one right here is i
mean we'll fix that later but uh okay it
was so cold downstairs and it's so warm
up here and now i'm in this like
survival jacket i'm very warm this is i
can't watch the sweat on my head yeah
it's it's pretty moist we it's super
duper warm i had to take off the collar
you see now can i take this off right
now hold on i want to show you guys the
the map the map is actually a spoiler
it's incredible am i allowed to show
this uh you're showing it now but
inside the jacket how cool is this the
map top secret not secret anymore oh
wait no i actually don't know if i was
allowed to show that yeah anyways
we have a series on our hands maven
we're jumping into map number three
it's gonna be the final game between
team big and team lil we're gonna be on
how do i put this back on i don't know
those big old arms you know you gotta
stop working out seriously how do i do
this
i think i just tore my acl oh no
all right all right
this is the battle of berlin map
so it's super it's nice it's dark with
lots of lights i just want the big boy
beard look at that triple b
it it truly is i need a big boy win yeah
i need team big win we need that
absolutely but we'll see if he can get a
position right now it looks like he was
sort of inspecting the ceiling maybe the
ground just trying to find his bearings
somehow
kind of what i saw
so you know listen the pro player pov is
going to be like different than some
more artists
you see here just checking out the
typewriter there may be looking into
doing some guest work but now he's been
put through the desk and absolutely
annihilated from behind oh yeah when
you're just ads in the entire time it's
unfortunate not able to really see
what's in the peripherals
but hopefully he's learned moving on
we're gonna keep following on with big
sean as he goes outside look at this
that's a beautiful view he's just a
standby for everyone to see hey i'm
right here but i'm gonna get one kill
maybe but not before he goes down
i'm going to switch on over to lil tekka
all right show me something little tiger
show me the gunning the movement there
the gun he got pointing at that i like
spicy
man hitting the shots yeah he would look
around
anybody see that there we go now there's
shots there's guns on point movement was
there that was that was the other thing
that beauty now unfortunately dead but
you win some you lose something when it
comes to call of duty yeah it's super
hot right in that inside
all right we got some more smiling
happening from slasher we know everyone
loves that apparently that's you know
new for me new information for me you
guys can see the grin on maven's face
right listen he he's he's on land right
he put this guy online even in this
competition like he'd still be a frown
on his face i guarantee it
zuma's over here have you seen him smile
this much no right yeah it's good to see
you by the way you're looking good
wow i mean look you're running through
and you see these floors already busted
open
so much destruction happening i want to
see if anybody's going to be able to get
another aerial strike we can get some
other
environmental destruction yeah that's
that's what i'm really excited to see
like how it has impact whether you're
talking about casual player at the
professional level somewhere players
here
yeah with the map getting smoked by
trying to help out the plays of these
players
how much is it gonna end up affecting uh
some of the strategies some of the
setups that they're gonna be trying to
do but a nice little sneaky position
unfortunately this shot's a little bit
sl a little bit shaky i think it's
slasher it's gonna get this snapper
hey but we see team pig coming in hot
right there bunch of bodies right here
on the point they're getting a lot of
points
great defense oh contested but look at
that clean it up all right you know what
this is what i'm talking about team big
coming in coming in good clutch right
here with this hardpoint happening this
building is really open come on enable
hit it
throw it back pistol out
ah he got double or triple by the point
but the swarm comes in the rest of his
team just gets chopped down i think that
was a six man clearance around the
hardpoint
as though i'll be spawning out and
trying to race back into the action
how many can they chain together a
little bit of duo work here the teamwork
on point the trade's there effectively
that was great gun play
all right one spot at the weight loss
we love the banter with our players so
let's bring it right back over to our
celebrity players right now and hear
what they have to say
[ __ ] that [ __ ]
somebody
fighting that action yeah
[Music]
you know what i'm saying
i got a [ __ ] [ __ ] kill [ __ ]
oh i see you little john with that weak
ass [ __ ]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] you t-bang
club
oh
a week ago
oh [ __ ]
damn
i'm tired of this [ __ ] me too man
come on y'all man y'all keep leaving
this [ __ ] what you mean come on y'all
are waiting on a [ __ ] to run up behind
look damn look at that
coming up behind us though what's up
oh [ __ ] come on
really
[Music]
oh
[Music]
who the [ __ ] keeps getting the playing
through
[Music]
[Applause]
on it
[Applause]
that was incredible
that was incredible but a beezy with the
flamethrower t-pain that was something
okay
little giant clapped at the end it was
amazing
yeah that was hilarious um
team big i got to feel like you fell a
little short only a little
only a little
uh we did you know what sean sean john
you did the most impressive thing
that entire match
you didn't kill a bunch of people
you didn't go crazy your kd wasn't super
great but guess what you actually got on
the [ __ ] hard point
instead of trying to run around the map
and kill people and that's something
that is very important
you actually took the chair and you saw
you saw enemies there and you jumped
over that crate and actually got on the
hardpoint and that is rare my friend
that is rare so thank you for your
service but guess what you [ __ ] lost
and so
uh
ladies and gentlemen give it up for team
yeah
i can't do it i don't have a good little
job
i still i've been working on it since
2009
but i will say this team lill
your knight ain't quite over with
because if you thought that was all the
beef that we was going to have you
settled tonight my dog you are wrong
we're like my dad's barbecue eat all the
[ __ ] because if you can make me throw
something away i'm beating everybody's
ass and i'm pulling guns out we're not
doing that tonight okay
it's time for the prize fight of the
evening ladies and gentlemen
i present to you
the title card events
in one corner
we have team lill
that's right make some noises man it's
fine they came out swinging ready to
fight ready to do their [ __ ] they won
all three rounds that's that was
actually kind of weird i didn't think
that was gonna happen
they already run the series tonight but
can they take home the championship
guys
they're not only rappers
they're not only gamers
but they're goddamn beasts and i love it
let's give it up one more time for team
lil guys one more time
[Applause]
i don't think that's your line that's
not your line i don't think you can do
that i don't think you're allowed to do
that and walk off with all that money we
just paid you um
it
a lot of money that's crazy
in the other corner
weighing in
with a crispy ass 3.4 kd ratio
known for their stealthy tactics and
mastery of the 360 no-scope shoot [ __ ]
right in the deck
fueled by salty tears
and a family-sized bag of wrapped snacks
you may know them as friends but ladies
and gentlemen i know them as amigos
[Applause]
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
boy
hey fellas i definitely over transferred
this [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did i do
ladies and gentlemen give it up for me
guys
there it is that was an ad lib out of
nowhere
guys
how you guys feeling tonight
feeling good feeling good feeling good
you're blessed who blessed god is the
greatest
god is the greatest look at that guys oh
my god look
it's a fierce matchup tonight you got
team lil over here uh i don't know how
much well you know what said i know you
play call of duty michelle quay i've
only seen you play once take up i just
don't
i feel like i feel like you're gonna
need some help tonight you're gonna be
good
oh follow me okay you got you got you
got we good we gonna be good okay so
check this out check this out
this is gonna be a match made in [ __ ]
hell this is gonna be this is gonna be
a train wreck that none of us can look
away from
but we're bringing in some backup to
help even out the matchup of the night
give it up for little honey
lord he's coming down we got it
come on come on you got this you got
this
what's popping what's popping
little honey migos
big collab [ __ ] you heard me
oh you guys got all nice pants i feel
like i
feel like i got help with the nice pan
[ __ ] tonight but anyways look all the
trash has been talked the feelings have
been hurt
are we ready to roll people are we good
all right teams taking places maven lucy
up to you everybody make some noise one
more goddamn time come on now
[Applause]
all right thank you thank you getting
hyped up ready to go for our next set of
matches and
i don't know we saw a little bit of
everything uh as far as
i i think the only thing i took away
from that that i really truly loved
outside of the gameplay is 100 just the
trash talk from the players like i can
listen to their comms literally forever
i mean yes that's why i'm so glad that
they've created the versus games
platform and the the series there if you
will because i'm sure we're going to be
seeing a lot more of that action going
down for sure over there
because yes that's why people streamers
do right go and see what their banter is
now i'm gonna be a little bit distracted
because uh
christopher crowder is on one of the
teams and
he's incredibly handsome talented uh one
of the greatest players of all time one
of the greatest coaches of all time one
of my best friends and i might i might
be in love with him oh
so much love here and uh at the vanguard
world premiere it's gonna be very
overwhelming for me but i think that i'm
prepared to do this you think you can do
this are you sure you can do this you
can handle it yeah we don't need to get
a replacement someone doesn't need to
pop in i'm not sweating this hot anymore
it's because zuma's three feet from me
and i've got crowder on my screen and
yeah i mean
should we just get zuma in here i mean
we keep talking about him come on get
over here buddy all right
right now do we have a headset for you
oh hey
wait what do we do okay here let's
listen check this out
we're three highly intelligent beautiful
people
what's up buddy look this is the casting
does it work do we hear you i look at
the hair you guys hear me i hear you i
do look look at how dapper you are they
they said red carpet and like you two
really killed it i have a t-shirt and
jeans you look phenomenal oh thank you
he looked good you just need the
vanguard jacket
i don't got a jacket what is that thank
you man they're killing me i appreciate
that maybe you guys like retirement
we're tired of 20 000 subs in a week
what are you gonna do i'm having fun and
having a lot of fun
all right well i think we're gonna be
diving in here getting up our final
matchup of the nights between these two
teams and we've been giving these
players a lot
to do but uh so much incredible stuff
has been happening and i don't know
about you maven and that's a flick but
i've been having a great time you've
been able to watch the game so far are
you having a great time oh yeah i'm
having a fantastic time some of these
guys can play man lil john i don't know
but everybody else is doing their thing
no i saw i think there's a little
technique that saw us like you know
you're playing in some of these pros
like you were looking pretty good he's
like yeah it's just like online i'm
still dropping 20 plus i was like okay
all right
all right a couple of the povs though
i'm not entirely sure they knew where
they were at all times um there's a
little bit of that you know look at the
ceiling and stuff you know it's first
time playing the title just gotta get it
all calibrated maven you know you don't
want it
warm-up games
hashtag warm-up but uh so let's get to
our final series like i said it's gonna
be first game on domination it's gonna
be played on decoy and when i said on
domination i mean domination on decoy
you know in this map it's a small mock
town made up of construction materials
and plywood so tons of
explosions and breakables
and it's gonna be a lot of fast and
chaotic gameplay it sounds like the
italian stallion if you've ever heard it
fast and chaotic
hitting the flank he's coming for you
when you see a new title come out like i
know listen
the retired life's been good to you
let's be honest it's been great let's be
honest it's been good to you but you
gotta you gotta miss it a bit right oh i
miss him every day i i honestly just
watching people compete it just brings
back a lot of memories and i'm honestly
so excited to just watch what happens
next season man i mean the just the
rosters man just look insane dude yeah i
i have no idea we're kind of we're kind
of covered at all over here right
because we've got uh you know the casual
side of things we've got some
celebrities here we have some pro
players here so having a former
professional player we're gonna wear a
chat a little bit of that stuff too but
yeah i don't know the season's gonna be
just with all the roster stuff going
into it i've got no idea what to expect
and then a new title it's like who knows
but i feel like there's some familiar
aspects but then again you got 10
attachments per gun i don't know what
people are going to be coming up with
listen man the game looks dope it does
game looks like the maps look good the
gun plays really good so i mean it's
going to be sick i was watching sally
running around he already looks
comfortable in a game like i'm like come
on man he's a freak nah he's he's
incredible he's already setting the tone
you're dropping all of the i can't what
there's something about the like he just
got the hair what do you call it how
would you describe that like curly thing
he's got going on there no idea an afro
what is it like a brillo pad or an after
umbrella pad
look at the outfit
with the jacket on today though i know
that's what i'm saying but did you see
the jacket i'm like damn good i've never
seen that in my life oh here we go we're
starting it back up it's time to get
back in oh yes it's going to be spicy
guys that's the business that's what i'm
talking about a lot of business i want
to see some classes i got on
i got on twitter for like two seconds
between like the last segment and i said
all i saw was like call of duty and like
all the official accounts like called me
out blasting me for leaking the map on
the jacket i was like ah they did
perfect it it's happening hopefully
that's all in good fun i'm not actually
getting fired which that's what a world
premiere is for you know admittedly you
did it i thought i think i'm gonna fire
every show i do so
all right we're jumping into a gameplay
all right we're gonna
take away your jacket privileges from
you maven but
see a lot of people rocking the stg's
the mp40s
a lot of people using the same guns
well i mean
i think those have been
just staples from when you get back into
world war ii period right like
oh look at this this is the mix right in
the middle of the map
little john coming out with it
what do you think of that hat did i pull
that off
absolutely you can pull up thanks man
i think you've teamed with like
everybody that's in this thing you've
got your team of crowder you team at the
scene you team with enable like you play
with all these guys at some point i sure
all these guys oh my god
all right we got a new blood in here
right team we goes coming through
they're talking a lot of smackdown
well i think it's lucy it's always
interesting like
i don't know every time i do one of
these and there's like uh celebrities
and stuff involved there's always like a
few of them like okay like they grind
like you know like even even back to you
know playing playing war zone and stuff
like there'll be some nfl athletes in it
so i'm like this guy this guy's nasty
where does he find time to put in or
like i'm about to play with lando norris
like an f1 racer i was like this guy's
disgusting like where does he have time
to do this he's traveling every week to
go to a different part of the world but
the passion for call of duty just around
the globe is
it's kind of nuts just the size of the
brand oh it's crazy i was out front
today and i saw chicharrito i was losing
my mind
come on that's that's like
playing some cod i saw ace and pop a
three piece
i saw ace and popping three pieces he's
going to smoke these guys man i feel
like asap is about to go nuts
yeah the pro player is going to give him
a chance or go far but the trash talk
has been amazing it's been going on
throughout hopefully you guys are
enjoying the show let's get to a listen
in here with the players they continue
on to the fight
what a gang get man
oh
i love it
looks like everybody's having fun man
it looks like fun
not really 66 what the [ __ ]
it's gotta do
oh wait what what did he just
oh
man come on brother
[Music]
[Music]
okay
okay
[Music]
[Music]
okay
[Music]
enemies
[Applause]
[ __ ]
[Music]
little john was having a little reaction
there okay can you i can't do it like he
does can you do an actually name i
absolutely cannot no no
i think my favorite member of that i
mean we're going back by 90 seconds oh
what is he going to see what are you
like a six piece of flamethrower
he's like what the f is that he's got
fire
the flame thrower
is really good
oh my
[Music]
we've had a couple over the years oh
yeah i've gotta have a lot of tvs
[Applause]
they're fired up the trash toss so so so
good there's no way you can see through
all right
should we just keep this up here is that
going to be is that going to be a thing
for tonight
what did you do you got you okay you're
good yeah yeah you're really good
feeling good feeling good okay
hey i want to just uh send a shout out
real quick little tucker did not come to
[ __ ] around tonight and
ro latega is smacking [ __ ] for
real right now
oh my god that boy came to eat booty and
he will have it
are we playing again
have you ever played this map
team migos you guys gonna now set
set i've actually seen you play call of
duty what's going on tonight i'll try a
little eight piece yeah
hey man hey man don't not get
straightened but straighten it man we're
gonna hit it right y'all just you came
to get straightening and now
look at this big ass graphic on the
screen what's going on over here
take off i i understand
hey i can see y'all playing i haven't
seen y'all playing but but but set i
figured you would carry the team the
first time we met you was like brother
you played call of duty i was like yeah
i play call of duty
you didn't tell me you didn't
okay all right come on watch this guys
last one last one it's a lot going on
tonight
how y'all feeling about gameplay right
now because
thanks one person
all right we gonna get back into it man
i've done all i can
second round
we need to get to it let's go
here we go here we go back into it
what do you say like i don't know who a
seam is or where he's at but he had 57
kills
i want to see the migos turn up here
well i think i saw clay clay tweeted
he's like black you know lmfao like
they're just they're just going at him
there's no mercy
yeah well hopefully we're gonna see some
competition on this second game it's
gonna be patrol again so we're gonna see
that moving objective point around the
map we're gonna be playing on daw's
house maybe uh you want to talk to us a
little bit about what this map is like
i'll tell you what that's that that's
the one that i had to ask to make sure i
was pronouncing it correctly it's almost
like what was the was the force now that
i always said if i was gonna screw up
back
oh yeah no it's arden yeah but i people
would say or dennis and i'm like that's
not correct yeah
i don't know what i'm saying no but this
is uh located remote wooded location in
germany it's map features small interior
focused combat within a mock a west wing
so another fast-paced close-quarters
combat matchup lies ahead and uh yeah
that zoom that's where you live and
thrive but
this uh have you played patrol much like
i find it interesting because hardpoint
has been a part of our like
dna for a long time during debate it was
interesting it was a lot of fun because
it was so different you're constantly on
the move you're constantly playing for
those spawns so it was fun it was a lot
of fun it just seems to me like it would
be something that
i don't know
would be fun for casuals and maybe have
like a little bit more of a competitive
side of it yeah for sure
lucy if we throw you in there right now
you dropping 40
um maybe 39. i'm not losing the gunfight
to a scene that much i'm sure of
definitely not to enable
i want to know how they're playing with
these glasses on it's actually fantastic
i wouldn't be able to see anything
maybe that's the play maybe that's the
unless they know something i don't know
what is this like you guys don't realize
it's like poker really trying to hide
they're trying to hide their tails with
their sunglasses on i don't know if it
works that way but i i respect it
this map a lot of close quarter combat
is getting mixy
yeah lies okay did you hear from my very
distinct definition i read the map there
that was very good thank you okay
all right well they keep going at it and
uh yeah i'm sure you guys at home one of
the best parts this is 100 for the trash
talk of the cops we're gonna go back to
a listed in the man that dropped 57 map
one a seam is on your screen let's get
to it
[Music]
oh my god
that's crazy
come on bro little hoodie okay
here we go
[Music]
man i have to reload
oh my god
keep landing behind me behind me into my
left
hey
oh
[Music]
stop it
[ __ ]
catch away
[Music]
[Music]
all right there we go
oh
looking like we are having our squads
it's not one-sided affair it just keeps
on going in that direction team will pop
it up looking for that blue again he
said who's kind of coming out a little
bit and they are almost to the finish
line of team will's is crushing the
competition but here's it that's the
play you got to do the lean maven yeah
no he looks funny far too comfortable
i'm loving it though i have to be like
in my monitor basically
did anyone see that like body that was
over the pool table that looked someone
got smoked was that somebody who had
died there i think so i i don't care
yeah no i think it was something that
got smoked yeah and they were it did not
look comfortable at all
these guys must have insane chemistry
because they are frying the littles
nobody can take these guys down man
now they they're absolutely cracked this
guy's twisting absolutely on a tear
ah
i all i know is i haven't seen crowder's
pov much
he's basically phil jackson to call of
duty he better be put in work hey
crowder's the ghost man
there's so many everywhere we got to go
to the screen ladies
oh there he goes he's on top he's pacing
well he's piece of i think he's on the
receiving end though unfortunately so he
well he put up 67 who had 85 whoa
we got to see him again
hey it was we got 85
we should just keep this on the screen
i started drinking a little while ago so
listen check it out right
john you're filming this john you won't
you wanna you wanna you wanna bask you
wanna bask in the glory that you didn't
help achieve at all you didn't help at
all john i got like 15 kills today you
got 15 kills today
i don't today today
to date or today today [ __ ]
since the first call of duty came out
today stop hating
that [ __ ] you got zero kills a day i
saw nothing no that's how you get killed
22 times i got three in that last game i
got you know what being that little
giant is standing up now is a good time
to bring up the ragdoll physics uh did
you see it happened a lot because i feel
like that was good as hell you got
killed a lot john yes i did but i came
you came back a lot you came back the
same amount of times you got killed 22.
that was crazy as hell did you see that
[ __ ] what does that say up there
[ __ ] [ __ ]
that says half of your name it's not
online
it's about the team it's about the team
absolutely absolutely yeah the squad
[ __ ] i'm sure i'm sure i'm sure
everybody
everybody that's on the team with every
great player is saying that it's about
the team right now yes exactly
team amigos
yo i had 37 killed yeah i had a 28 piece
take what you had a dog you had a dub
just two
yeah
yeah two on top 20 20
that was a whole bunch of lies damn
i can't believe y'all lied to me in my
face
i love y'all bro y'all my brothers you
know no no no just check the stats so
obvious ladies and gentlemen
the lils have it make some noise for the
lils
[Music]
i didn't know they were selling those at
the front that was crazy
damn
i'm sorry we can't give y'all another
round
it's over
it's settled
undisputed
you've taken the series and won the
championship
little tekker how do you feel brother
you feel good you just
that's just the way you went with it
that's right 53 kills
yeah
everybody's good over there man
[Music]
john you feel like you helped for real
[Music]
all right i'll take that ladies and
gentlemen
let's give it up one more time for the
winners of the very first versus call of
duty vanguard edition team leo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
all right okay
all right shut up
[Music]
y'all know
that i love multiplayer right
but what i got for you next nice
i've been waiting on for a long ass time
and i'm sure a lot of you guys have been
waiting on this [ __ ] too
it's the biggest release of the year
it's the only
island vacation i'm gonna be taking
other than dr because
prostitution is legal
ladies and gentlemen
hold up hold up hold up y'all talking
too much no can't do it y'all talking
too much
all right
hold up hold up hold up hold up because
i want this i want this to sound good i
want this to sound good
ladies and gentlemen
i give you
the first look
at the all-new
war zone pacific
[Applause]
let's go
[Music]
someone started the party without us
let's move
we've got company
keep your eyes peeled
you see that [ __ ]
[ __ ] nazis hope they're all still
burning in hell
turn around show us those hands don't do
anything stupid i heard you a mile off
no offense if i'd meant you any harm
you'd already be dead how about we start
with who the [ __ ] are you and what the
[ __ ] are you doing here
relax gents
we're on the same side
i'm captain butcher of the soe
well
retired captain butcher these days
i was in charge of the soe during the
war
everett of vanguard
i created vanguard and all the others
too
it was a simpler time then
[Music]
but the work is never done
our victory wasn't until we snuffed out
every last spark
after berlin
we hunted down the rats that scurried
into hiding all over the world
and it started
in the pacific
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whoa okay okay okay
all right okay all right
all right
um
i'd have it i didn't have a meeting
about this earlier but
[ __ ] is them was the planes was them
regular planes
are we dog fighting in war
zone think we're dog fighting in the war
zone
they didn't tell me [ __ ] they just kept
me in the dark they were just like
wearing multiple jackets and you'll be
fine
god damn
all right check this out guys real quick
i do want to tell you something though
obviously
call of duty cares about our veterans
guys
that's why they form the call of duty
endowment which which supports and helps
veterans get jobs
and honor and respect
of their service
real [ __ ]
so
they're releasing a special call of duty
endowment pack to raise money and
support our veterans
let's take a look
[Music]
hell yeah
i don't know about y'all that was the
first thing i got when modern warfare
happened um
guys obviously it's been an incredible
night
we've seen courage and play-through of
the epic vanguard
campaign
we got to see the first ever versus call
of duty multiplayer battle and settle
some beef uh obviously the lils handled
that beef very quickly uh
medium well
we've seen the new thrilling zombies and
the epic war zone pacific
which i'm gonna be in love with and now
our night is over but
i just got word through my fake earpiece
i just got a word to my fake earpiece
that the migos actually wanted to say
one last thing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
roger okay
uh-huh
amigos
what you got to say
amigo
yes sir
[Applause]